Okay, let's do this exercise together.
David, what did you come up with
the labels with the various links?
>> So, I looked at the vocabulary
we used over here and
decided to use the same
vocabulary over here.
Just like z was above both x and
y, t is above both s and r.
So, I said t is above s and
t is above r.
Just like y was inside x, s is inside r.
So I said that s is inside r.
Over here I saw that s is above r,
just like y was above x,
so I said s is above r.
>> Now David made
an important point here,
he said that the vocabulary
he's using here of inside and
above is the same as the vocabulary that
I had used of inside and above here.
And that's a good point because we
want to have a consistent vocabulary
throughout the representation for
the class of problems.
So here we have decided that for
representing problems of this kind
in semantic network we will use
a vocabulary of inside and above and
we'll try to use it consistently.